[Music]
after launching a deep one that'll leave
time here but Paul George he lets it go
just beyond NASA's defenders around in
the
we kind of have fluid up there to the
delight of this crowd it goes in
George
[Applause]
we talked about access denied at the rim
ball George just perfect timing to not
foul and not go to that ball at the fast
break opportunities 17 nothing now
Westbrook creates another one this time
it's George on the other end and the
windmill
no he did good ball shorts windmill in
transition and he'll was nice
you gotta think Paul George has to get a
touch at some point and he does the
three ball quickly
all on the job incredible that was an
incredibly great shot lunch
Paul George now with 30 points with over
10 George wants to win it to the Thunder
the floating shot let's go
[Applause]
the Pichu
is he special or what
whoa
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's a pic 3 is at the other
remaining that was great defense on that
plane the shot over the back where
that's a horse shot is xxx
30 point game of the season Westbrook
double-team that given us right back to
Westbrook quarter three George
[Applause]
chef's prepare George
that's what the Thunder has done tonight
they've denied the drive pretty
[Applause]
for the plush school
pg-13 I'm gonna go sniff on your bed get
a right leg up on come on Petey there's
George puts it on the floor his pants
too
and at Paul George man the assertiveness
to attack the freak and give them a
bucket what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content